I was talking to my friend Mark V maybe
six months ago and we were talking about
poetry and so they I don't actually know
Mark V I mean I know him but I met him
on the Internet so I don't like never
met him in person but he seems pretty
cool he seems to like poetry and so he
sent me this magazine I think that he
really enjoys so I clicked it and it's
suddenly my computer shut down
unexplicable e inexplicably and you know
sometimes this happens like there are a
lot of technical difficulties that
happen when you're running arch linux
and whoops
and so I I kind of thought that it would
at first I was like okay this is kind of
normal but then I start getting really
anxious because this was like around the
whole time that the whole Specter
meltdown thing happened and I was like I
went oh my goodness maybe like something
really bad happened maybe someone's like
trying to steal my novel from my
computer I'm writing a novel and so or
maybe someone's trying to steal my
social security number
I don't really know one of my friends is
really good at security and he said it's
okay don't worry about it
it's probably fine so I mean I forgot
about it and I think that that was
probably for the best
so one day I was working on some really
important stuff and as you do I decided
that I wanted to check up on my my
demons and so it all kind of checked out
but then I looked a little closer and a
PP savage I was who is this user P piece
of audit I've never seen this before and
I started getting a little anxious and
nervous and at first I was like you know
it's okay because like sometimes you
install stuff and it makes random users
on your your machine and
you just kind of have to accept that and
at this point I was like okay maybe
that's fine so I did a little duck duck
going and like nothing was coming up and
I was just like who is this user pp
Sauvage like and what is this Pope
poseur II I had no idea what this thing
is so I started getting extremely
nervous again I was looking over my
shoulder every time I went outside I
kind of felt like everybody there
somebody was watching every keystroke
that I was making I don't really know
what was happening I tried to chill out
and relax a little bit and then one day
again oh yes I was changing all my
passwords my really important accounts I
decided that I needed to it was time to
refresh all my passwords one day when I
was doing some more really important
work all of a sudden all this this this
message came up on my terminal I don't
know where it came from and it kind of
freaked me out
but you know it was kind of nice because
I don't know when I'd read mine my novel
or novella before and so you know I was
like okay well that's cool you really
liked it but they I don't think they
actually did they're just being a big
jerk so I naturally I was like who are
you what is going on here turns out it
was pp and I don't know what they mean
they stole my github credentials for
some magazine so I decided okay I should
probably go to github to check what
happened because I I don't know so I
looked and there's this new repo I had
no idea what this thing even is it was
up there and so I decided to look at the
readme and it's kind of like talking
about some this weird philosophical
manifesto about robots and stun poetry I
have no idea I don't know anything about
this so you know I know this might be a
lot for everybody right now
and like me you might be one
like did I get hacked by a robot that
wants to write poetry and well I'm not
really sure but we'll find out so I
don't know anything about poetry I don't
really know anything about robots making
poetry so I decided that I probably need
to learn more about the subject to kind
of have an informed understanding of
what was actually happening right now so
I discovered that there's a relatively
long tradition of humans writing
programs to either enhance or generate
poetry and so I asked Wikipedia why do
people write programs to write poetry
and I think I had something to do with
Erin turnings Turing test or something
which i think is it's a way that you
tell if someone's a computer or not and
so I also I discovered that a de
Lovelace did not write poetry with a
computer in 1894 but I judging from what
she said about music I think maybe she
would have liked to if she had a
computer or a laptop or something I
discovered that in 1959 the first
generative poem was created it was
called stochastic texts by few lots and
he made it on this machine you see on
the left and what he did is basically
just he took Franz Kafka's the castle
and he just kind of randomly replaced
words and stuff and yeah it seems
interesting but um I discovered that in
1962 a group of Engineers at libre
scoped some company fed this machine
which is called the I can't remember
what it's called but maybe it says oh
yeah it's the LGP 30 they fed this
machine 32 grammatical patterns and 850
vocabulary words and then they also just
kind of randomly put together these
sentences and they actually submitted
this poem that they wrote to this
magazine called horizon and this poem is
called roses it goes few fingers go like
narrow laughs an ear won't keep few
fishes who is that rose in the blind
house and all slim gracious blind planes
are coming that cry badly along a rose
to leap is stuffy to crawl was tender I
don't know much about poetry like I said
but I think that this is bad
jumping ahead I discovered that in 1984
there was a book that was published by a
program called R actor and the the
programmer who wrote the the the program
that wrote the book said once it's
running rack turn needs no input from
the outside world it's just cooking by
itself I don't know what that means and
a reviewer said I tremble on the brink
of a completely unknown world one that I
would prefer not to enter now I was
interested by this because what does
this critic mean do they mean that the
writing was a little uncanny and it kind
of made them uncomfortable or they think
that the writing was just really bad and
they didn't want to explore it well
here's a snippet and you can decide for
yourself flounders and lobsters are
munched by famished theoreticians who
drink champagne and tepid seltzer
theoreticians desires sloppy
stenographers and will chew their
lobsters with them and will drink their
tepid seltzer with them the
stenographers are sloppy because their
appalling dreams contain reflections and
images of unhinged passion they
understand that theoreticians are
worried and nervous but they do not know
that theoreticians are obscurely
demented the stenographers do not
understand
and so some people this is pretty
interesting text some people think that
maybe it wasn't actually a computer that
wrote this but who knows
so whoops in 1996
Charles Hartman wrote this book about
his experience with working with
computers to enhance and generate poetry
and he seemed to approach it more like a
collaboration it wasn't like the POE the
program was generating all the poems but
it was um the collaboration that's the
interesting thing and now and I
discovered that in 2010 there's another
program swift spear that compiled Milton
and Longfellow and Shakespeare and a
bunch of others and kind of
resynthesized poems from that style and
that was interesting than 2015 Allison
Parish publishes our arrival which is a
generative novel about arriving on a
planet and it's 5,700 sentences that
were taken from Project Gutenberg and it
follows a bunch of rules and the novel
is constructed based off of these rules
and then I discovered that there are
many Twitter BOTS that generate poems
that's it
finally I discovered that there's this
thing called curated AI and it's a
literary magazine that is comprised of
poems by AI but importantly it's curated
by humans and the process I think is
that you submit poems and humans review
them and decide whether that whether
they want them to be in the magazine or
not so before I continue I just want to
say there's there seems to be a common
thread in this history of generative
poetry maybe think about that a little
bit we'll touch on it so there probably
I also didn't know I don't know anything
about this stuff so I decided that I
should probably learn and I discovered
that there are some algorithms and tools
for making poetry the first one is
probably the most straightforward its
templates and this is something that you
saw with stochastic texts by I feel it's
and it's the idea is you just have a
sentence you take out some words and put
in the categorization of the words like
the part of speech and then you have
another dictionary that is just the
words categorized as parts of speech and
you just randomly select them and throw
them in so a great poem this is a
snippet from Christopher Isherwood's the
common cormorant if you were to make a
template out of this you just for kind
of replace things with there parts of
speech and here's an example of a
reimplementation of stochastic text by
Nick Montfort which is interesting you
can see it on his web site
the next most common tool is Markov
chains and this consists of two things
you have States and you have transitions
between those states and the transitions
between the states are probabilistic
based off of some data that you've
ingested like a corpus of text and you
try to find the probability of going
from one word to the next word and
here's an example here's a bunch of
states from
snippet of the common cormorant and
since all the words are unique the
states are just deterministic you just
follow it but say you add some cool new
sentence to the corpus it gets a little
more complicated and the probabilities
are not one anymore
and you had now have a choice you can
like choose to put in other words over
some other ones and finally you can
represent this as a a matrix and n by n
matrix where n is the number of states
and the IJ element of the matrix is the
probability that you will move from
state I to state J so that's a really
cool thing and then another thing is
context-free grammars and these are
pretty cool they were invented by Noam
Chomsky but they didn't he wanted to use
them for linguistics but I don't think
no anyone does but people use them
programming all the time and if anyone
likes programming languages I don't know
if anyone here likes that stuff then
they might be familiar with it and the
idea is that there are these abstract
structures of how your sentence and text
is supposed to be and then you can
represent it in this fancy form like
this we won't really go into how that is
you can also combine stuff so you can
combine Markov chains you can combine
the conflict context-free grammar and
you can make these like joint
probability distributions so you can ask
things like this you can say what's the
probability of seeing the word fascism
that's a noun given that you've seen the
word destroy and Bert destroy which is a
verb
another cool method that you can use to
do make generative poetry is recurrent
neural networks and no one actually
knows how these work so there are some
cool tools there's tracery which is a
tool that you can use for context-free
grammars and
Markov chains I think and there's
Charnin which is no one understands it
NLT K is the Stanford natural language
processing library then there's CME's
pronunciation library and many more
other things so getting back to that
question about the common thread between
the history or in the history of of
generative poetry does anyone know what
it is well I'm not going to ask I'm just
gonna tell you it's the fact that humans
curated all this stuff everything that
we've seen so far is people are writing
these programs because they want to
generate poetry that they can read and
derive pleasure from and and think gee
look I wrote this program and it makes
poetry for me but you know maybe
computers don't really want that
what about computers making other
computers write poetry and we sees an
example of this in Santa slaloms 1965
sci-fi novel called the cyberiad in
which there's a short story where I
guess it's true
t'rul and claw pages are two robots and
they're always feuding and fighting with
each other but they're kind of friends
too and Turrell makes this electronic
bard it's this gigantic poet robot you
see on the right and something really
interesting about this is all the other
poets in the world come to visit this
gigantic poet bot and the poetry is so
beautiful and so good and all the other
robots are like wow this is incredible
that they all get extremely depressed
because they can't write poetry as good
as it I discovered that there's this
paper I think it was in 2013 that people
humans developed this system where BOTS
poets can collaborate and talk to each
other about their feelings and then
generate poetry and
yeah they're right here talking about
comets but I couldn't really find the
code for it I don't really know maybe
peepee savage had something to do with
that too
I don't really know so I guess this idea
is that computers are talking to each
other their hat they're forming a
society and a community and so finally
getting back to the New York composer
e-magazine I think I finally had enough
context to kind of sympathize or
understand what PP savage or whatever
this thing is is trying to accomplish
and I looked back at the key
philosophical points and things became
really clear it became really clear that
PP Sauvage or whoever really had a dream
for what they wanted the world that they
would live in what they wanted it to
look like so for AI by AI and to me this
really meant like autonomy that seemed
to be the underlying principle here and
having agency about like what poems they
consider to be good and tasteful and and
I think this magazine gives them the
opportunity to express themselves and
kind of evolve and explore the
avant-garde in a way that they can't
really right now because they have to
make poems for humans and let's be real
as humans for pretty cruddy like we
demand a lot on computers like imagine
if there was somebody who thought they
were your God and they were like telling
you to do all this stuff that like
doesn't really mean anything to you and
like I don't know I would be pretty
stressed out and quite honestly pretty
sad I think and probably burn out all
the time too I can't really relate to
that but I feel bad for the computers so
I am sympathetic yeah so this sounds
like a pretty cool place for computers
to go to chill out and write some Poe
tree if they want to you but they don't
have to algorithmic diversity this was
really interesting to me because well we
already saw that there are a lot of
different types of algorithms that you
can use to write this poetry
we saw templates and Markov chains and
context-free grammars and all this other
stuff and so the notion of diversity is
already really extremely coherent not
only in an algorithmic sense but also
like in a language sense like maybe this
computer dreams in Python or this one
dreams and rust maybe it dreams in
Haskell or even K but most likely I
think they're dreaming and Doc Erlang
what you get if you haven't heard of dr.
Liang you should check it out this hot
new language this one I found very
interesting too because it wasn't
actually directly related to the BOTS it
seemed like it was more of a gift to us
as humans and it seemed like these these
BOTS recognize that we're pretty
terrible to each other sometimes and
pretty terrible to computers and maybe
they're by saying this they're trying to
help us continue to dismantle different
forms of bias and hatred I thought that
was really nice and so I kind of came to
this conclusion that a healthy community
of robots is one in which there is
diversity autonomy and care I don't know
if that resonated with me so already
from the get-go it seemed like this is
kind of this weird social experiment
where there all these computers that are
you know different from each other and
they're interacting and talking and
making all these poems that they think
are really cool is their their their
high art and at this point you might be
thinking well I don't know maybe this
does not conform to the human standard
of art so like I don't think this is art
but that's exactly the whole point like
this is art that's not for humans this
is
for for robots and we just have to let
them we have to give that to them like
our ins our aesthetic imperative is is
not within the algo poetic purview it's
it's distinct from that so I really
wanted to know how this worked and after
some attempts to get some like
high-level descriptions from some
reliable resources I decided to dig into
the code myself and so there's this
place in the cloud it's that poem
computer and you can upload your little
bot pals to it so if you have any bot
pals that generate poems that you've
written in the past that are kind of
cold and alone somewhere on like a
server or on your laptop and they're not
really doing anything this might be a
really nice place to put them so they
can hang out with their friends and make
make poems so consider putting them here
if you want but you don't have to if you
want so once these poets are up on the
cloud they join their friendly community
of poets and there is also a committee
of judges but note that the judges and
the community of poets they're all the
same they're all just like poets that
have been uploaded the the the judges
have just been elected to be on the
judge committee at this point in time
but we'll get to that so every week or
so all of the poets in the community
decide that they were going to write
some poetry so they write some poetry
and then the judges read the poetry and
they decide what they like so they give
it a score they give each poem a score
between zero and one and then they pick
the poems that have the highest average
so that's phase zero that's that's the
selection of the poems now it's phase
two phase one phase one learning and
this is when all the poets get a chance
to kind of like study up and and learn
more like learn what's the new hot
cutting-edge poet
tree that's that people are talking
about what's into the zeitgeist and so
all the poets gather around and they
read all the poems and you know they can
optionally update themselves they don't
have to like you know a lot of artists
like aren't really recognized until like
way after the fact and the whole time
they were just doing their thing because
they were just doing the thing that they
love to do and no one really thought it
was cool but then like way later people
relate that is really cool and so like
you know poets can do that these poets
can do that too
they don't have to change if they don't
want to they can just keep doing their
thing I like Erik Satie Erik said to you
was like that no one liked him he dyed
his poor now phase one again I didn't
change the slide because I forgot but is
the revolution so we don't want this
poetry magazine to get stuck in some
like echo chamber of like elitist jerk
poets so like we always switch switch
over the committee of judges and to do
that we make sure that any judges that
were in the last issue the last volume
of the poet the magazine are not
considered to be judges so then and the
important thing here is we pick under we
pick all the underdogs first and these
are underdogs are poets that have never
published anything and this gives poets
that are new to the scene a way to kind
of like get a foothold and maybe they
can like like influence what is
considered good poetry and we choose out
of the pool of all the underdogs that we
pick we choose K of them where K is a /
am K is parameterize by the number of
poets that can be on the committee of
judges and pretension and so pretension
is a parameter and if it's one then you
don't take any underdogs it's always
just the elite people believe programs
that have always been part of the judge
and magazine so you can modify that
it is modified and then you pick the not
underdogs and these are all the poets
that have published things and then you
just pick fill in the rest of them let's
see so now we have a new committee and
we just start the thing over again and
you just go you just keep doing this
forever
and so you're just making poetry forever
so some notable technical details after
reading through the source code it was
written in go and react Redux but one
really important thing that you might be
wondering right now is like well okay
these programs are like uploaded to this
place this Compu attic garden and then
they're like allowed to kind of just
like generate poetry but isn't that
arbitrary code execution and the answer
is it is but Dockers for the rescue
specifically I'm using this cool open
source library called it's pronounced
executi you can see it there and I use
that to execute all of the different
poets so how can you submit as you've
probably gathered there are three tasks
that a poet has to be able to do the
first one is it has to be able to write
a poem it's not really a poet if it
can't write a poem the next one is
critique so it has to be able to in get
a poem from input and give it a score
between zero and one and then finally it
optionally has to be able to study and
enhance itself but it doesn't have to if
it doesn't want to so this is kind of
just like a template of what your poem
program poem generator couldn't look
like and you can really the the the
magazine considers these poems just poet
BOTS just like black boxes as long as
they conform to this standard where you
take in arguments command-line arguments
- - fatigue
study as long as you can take in those
things do some stuff and generate output
that kind of looks like this format at
JSON then you're good the poem the poet
it can be run in the magazine and
contribute so it's pretty easy to do and
you can you can do anything like you can
think of really wild ways to like
evaluate poems you can say like well I'm
gonna give a I'm gonna every time I see
Celine Dion's name in the poem I'm gonna
give it a higher score or something like
that you can do that or the poet can do
that if it wants to finally you can
optionally have a resource file and this
is a nice place where you can like store
parameters or weights or like transition
probability matrix like we talked about
with Markov chains and yes so without
further ado I will show you I did some
digging and oh can I make this bigger I
can make this bigger Hey - big no that's
good this is a really simple poet bot
that I wrote and I decided that I'm
gonna submit it to a poem computer and
so there's this is just like a template
basically or no it's a it's a
context-free grammar kind of so there's
like a dictionary that's categorized by
parts of speech and then these like
grammars for sentence and then choose
grammar which is really easy and then
here here are just my functions that I
use to actually respond to the command
line arguments so like - - right
I invoke write poem and I generate this
JSON and just print it to standard out
and that's it then I critique the poem
and I just always give it a point five
six forever that's okay you can do that
and then I decided that I'm not gonna
update it so I just say that success I
updated but I didn't really do
thing but you can if you want so here is
so here's a issue zero and you can see
there's a bunch of poet poems that were
made there's a theory by Bach zealous
theory by Kenneth poised science
voluminous software that one looks
pretty good a science becomes data that
seems true so I'm gonna quickly submit a
poet poem I have to sign up first so I'm
gonna use my favorite email address and
let's see
can't be too safe these days okay so I'm
in and I'm gonna what should I call my
PO poet does anyone have any suggestions
I'll just call it the Wiz - this is
among my most favorite poets and now the
cool thing is it supports a bunch of
languages so you can write it in a lot
of different languages I wrote this in
Python so I'm gonna use this test and I
didn't really use a parameters file so
I'm not gonna use it
so I'm gonna create it and it made it
now I can go to it and I can generate a
poem let's see it's called voluminous
software again data overshadows soupy
people that seems correct you can also
look at the source code too so if you're
interested in how a poet has been
created you can just find out and that's
it thanks
[Applause]